Will often talk on the show about how on so many
different issues the country, meaning the voters
are as far left as they have been oftentimes for
as long as we've been keeping track of certain
metrics. So as an example will often say, well,
when you ask people, should abortion be legal,
in most cases, we have more approval for that.
Yes, abortion should be legal in most cases today
than at any point during the Roe we Roe v
Wade era, which started decades and decades
ago. We talk about gay marriage, for example.
We'll talk about, well, should the government
provide some basic level of health care to
everybody, regardless of ability to pay?
But another area in which public opinion
has shifted towards the left over the last
many years that does not get as much attention
is support for labor unions. Labor unions in
the United States are experiencing,
based on this brand new Gallup poll
that came out under two weeks ago, which I did
not talk about, but I'm talking about today,
approval for labor unions in the United States
is at its highest point since 1965. That's
57 years. And when you look at the numbers, you
now see that 68% of Americans currently approve
of labor unions. That's a number that bottomed
out at 48% in 2009. That got close to 68%
in the late nineties and early 2000. But you have
to actually have to go all the way back to 1965
where you see that support
for labor unions was at 71%.
Now, this is data that we have going back
a long way because Gallup has measured this
support for labor unions going all the way back
to 1936. And there was a period in the United
States from 36 to 67, roughly, where
if you're looking at this chart,
you see this graph, you see that there was
just generally higher support in that roughly
30 year period. You had an average of 68%
support for labor unions in the United States
that dropped into the mid-to-high fifties for
a while and went even lower around the time of
the Great Recession. But those numbers have now
recovered. And the interesting question would be
why? One part of this is when you break
down these numbers by party affiliation,
Democrats, Republicans, independents, it
won't shock you that support among Democrats
is where labor union support is highest. But even
among Democrats, labor union support has also hit
a 20 year high. Labor union support
among Democrats has always been higher
in this entire period, but it is particularly
higher right now as well. And to understand
what's going on, you need only look at sort
of the world around us. In the United States,
people are increasingly understanding that we need
some counterbalancing power or influence against
the power of corporations and against the power of
employers in the employee employer relationship.
This is a reaction to what is correctly being
seen out in the world the gig economy. More and
more people realizing how absurd the disconnect
between productivity and wages has become. Even
if you don't know that technically, even if you
don't have the data in front of you intuitively,
there is a sense of that. And it is true that on
some of these things, the pendulum sort of switch
swings back and forth and there are periods
where the country moves away from favoring labor
unions to some degree and moves back in
favor of labor unions. The key is what
can you get done when the pendulum is swinging in
your favor? What can you accomplish when support
is higher? I think it also should be mentioned
that President Joe Biden is arguably more
pro-union, vocally so than any recent president.
I mean, certainly in the last 20 or so years.
And he talks about it as well. And Joe Biden's
background riding the Amtrak train. Amtrak also
has been in the news for what appears to
be a narrowly averted major work stoppage,
a labor strike. Biden talks about that
certainly more than Trump. More than Obama,
of course, more than Bush. And I guess you
have to go back and think, well, is it sort
of like a Clinton level amount of talking about
labor unions? So none of this should shock us.
The optimistic thing is we often worry
and I talk about this on the show
all the time, that there's a disconnect
between what is happening in the country
and public opinion. So, for example,
you will see the Republican Party
swing cartoonishly and absurdly into this
MAGA world where there is no more policy.
It's authoritarianism and sort of fascistic,
dictatorial, wet dreaming in terms of what they
would like to see while claiming to be about small
government. What? It just doesn't make any sense.
And we sometimes see that the Republican Party
electorate or just voters in general, they don't
see the scope of what is happening within the
Republican Party. And this ends up with, you know,
Herschel Walker might defeat Raphael Warnock
in Georgia. And it's horrible. In other words,
we often are concerned that the people are not
reacting to the reality of what's going on.
The good news here, if we want
to find some good news beyond
just oh, it's good that people
are more in favor of labor unions,
is that this is an accurate and logical reaction
to what is happening in terms of the relationships
between employer and employee, in terms of the
disproportionate power that large corporations
have, not only with regards to their employees,
but also with regard to taxation and so many
other things. So this is good to see. The
question now becomes what's going to be done
about it? Will there actually be any steps
in terms of the democratization of work?
Joe Biden has ideas that are going nowhere
naturally because of what's going on in the Senate
right now in not having 60 votes. But we're going
to continue talking about it. And the first step
in achieving change is public opinion
uniting, and we're seeing that to some degree.